[Music]
so um
yeah there's a lot of uh
a lot of crimes going on around the
world oh crimes here we are back in l.a
guess what's going down on melrose
avenue oh my god i heard that there's
like super stupid amounts of robberies
they just busted they're just busting
them i mean i grew up going to miller's
avenue i don't go there at all now and i
live a minute away from it and i just
steer clear but yeah this is what just
happened i like to go to fairfax for
those thrift stores oh yeah yeah
sometimes it's not worth your life
though that's true
but that one dollar deal though on
sunday one dollar deal get some clean
corduroys i know
i'll die for a clean pair all right a
man stabbed the woman oh at melrose
avenue foot locker
oh my during an argument over the nike
dunk shoe release no way bro like in
line in line who likes dunks like that
anymore
so
what do you think they could be fighting
about
i think she i honestly cannot relate i i
get free shoes
oh
see you're just on a higher level
doesn't matter if you don't
that's right it doesn't matter like you
don't have to wait in line exactly okay
i want these and they're like oh you
want two other pairs
because i could cause like i i could get
it if it's like two opposing like rivals
of like shoes right there
like a feel of street team shows up
stabbing everybody that's never the case
they get mad over like
if you get like a ticket before them or
if sneaker heads get real because
they're both they're both trying they
both like the same thing that's probably
what they're unified over is they like
the shoe man i thought they were arguing
over who was the designer of what
they're like no that's not no that's
this guy oh they got that
it's on video the dude's stabbing her
you know you don't see like hey they
blurted out but you get you see the dude
and like the car is she okay
yeah she's fine she's good oh my god bro
come on ryan i'm sorry
it's his second day on the job give him
some people give him a break i didn't
know you guys want to hear it we do
you're like oh i don't know if i want to
see it but i want to hear the juice we
want to hear the argument hear the juice
there's some freshly squished persimmons
coming up ooh
well there's like two guys oh [ __ ]
oh it's a guy oh my god that guy right
why did it freeze him out of nowhere bro
they didn't want to show the real the
actual stab and then they just left her
yeah is she okay yeah she's all right
yeah oh my god
but like
over shoes and it was another guy came
out wait wait wait was it two men on one
woman yes yeah it was like i thought the
thing was another girl was like is that
a couple girls yeah she was like trying
to help her out and you know what stupid
now no one gets shoes but this is this
this is pretty common
though wait that's the thing
it's the walk away it's like no and now
i know it's like elementary school no
one goes to recently never though she
was back give me the show you never
stood in line for like drops back in the
day ever no damn cause i was wondering
if that's just like a regular occurrence
that does happen like
the travis scott shoes that came out so
i got that someone got shot i think i
got shot at the shoe pal the shoe pals
raffles i'm gonna straight up die i mean
that looks like some black friday kind
of [ __ ] right where you're waiting in
line
and then it's like the doors open and
you're like no i want the deal [ __ ]
like it's not even about shoes anymore
it's just about like getting what they
want yeah it's like get out of the way
so you think that 20 big screen tv [ __ ]
you
twenty dollars i might stop someone for
that people who died over like wait
don't remember that guy that got stabbed
to death over popeye's chickens
yes but hey that first bash of popeye's
chicken sandwich was to stab food yes
yes they missed out on a marketing
technique right
floor so good they'll stab you
and then they ran out and they like made
it again and it just wasn't to stop for
no more oh it wasn't really it wasn't
the same dude they changed something
dude but you can you imagine can you
actually dine getting to heaven or
wherever you're going afterwards and
then just like what how did you get here
it's like [ __ ] pop
chicken sandwich
popeye's drinking sandwich guys one of
my worst nightmares is that i die in a
whack-ass way and it goes viral yeah
[Applause]
i don't know like
like someone discovers you like like
strangling yourself while you're jerking
off or something like that i don't know
i was jaywalking or some [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] i got hit by a car that was
going in reverse but like a clown like a
clown car like something whack and then
like it goes on live leak and everyone's
talking [ __ ] and they're not [ __ ]
idiots let's go talk [ __ ] because that's
so no people will talk
people talk [ __ ]
i bet you could go to this one and find
people that are talking [ __ ] yeah
yeah someone can find this video and
find a way to talk [ __ ] about it she was
asking for it what a stupid [ __ ] like
you know there's all these crazy why
didn't she square up never fails that
there's a guy in the comments who goes
man a guy like me though i want to get
done on one of these
i'm like bro like shut up man
poor girl that's [ __ ] up bro i [ __ ]
up that guy did he really have to stab
her though that's what i'm saying could
it he couldn't just punch her or
something at least i mean for most
situations
these works just fine you gotta get a
knife like why did you have to bring a
knife in it what i don't know he's gonna
lose his [ __ ] life forever this
[ __ ] thing if there's two dudes you
don't even need a knife you can still
beat her ass up
you won't know the answer to all this is
because he is not afraid of the justice
system in this state oh we're going to
get political here huh we have to
because that's the reason why
everybody's stabbed you're right though
you're right because uh the prosecutors
in california do not want to file
charges so what it's doing is a lot of
people are just like well if i'm going
to get away with it [ __ ] it
a lot more fun really yeah so it's
easier to fight it's easier to steal
it's easier to do a lot of things uh
petty crimes whatever because people are
just like the [ __ ] it doesn't matter
because i'll get caught by a cop and
then they'll take me to get processed
and then the prosecutor won't prosecute
so i'm just released that's why all
these like uh luxury stores are getting
robbed smashing smashing grabs you might
as well take the risk because [ __ ] it's
a it's you're not gonna get in trouble i
would have never thought of memos people
would be getting robbed during brunch
sitting in the front of a cabinet steal
something small like a snickers bar like
a normal person you know what i mean you
don't have to
do this big crazy stuff just for the
thrill just bring your pocket and walk
out no but then that's not thrilling
anymore right a little bit your heart
beats up a little bit like give
as you're walking out you're like oh my
god i stole a snickers bar and you walk
out it's all good
just buy that
even even the [ __ ] armed robbers like
nick what do you think i am dude i'm
gonna [ __ ] honestly hold somebody up
and then buy a snickers bar because i'm
not an [ __ ] okay over it's it's this
it's like investing right over a period
of time you you steal something small
and then over the course of a month you
have a whole
that's the inventory it's melted already
and then it already melted and then you
resell all right okay
and it's all good
it's easy to just stick a gun up into
someone's face and get their wallet and
you got 600. but it's all profit bro
it's all profit of 22 dollars so is
robin's after a month
but it's safer overhead and rocks
it's the safer way to do it you guys
don't understand bro did you guys see
that one where the dude
got rolled up on
and he started shooting back yeah yeah
i'm nervous yeah and i was like melrose
yeah was it behind the store yeah this
guy rolled up and he was like oh [ __ ]
and he just started
so before those guys shot like he saw a
car stop
two guys got out they started going he
knew yeah the situation was and he got
his gun out started shooting them they
bounced yeah that was cool they bounced
yeah they're like oh get out of here
it's cool but like it sucks that that
dude's probably do more time than this
[ __ ] guy gta man you know well
hopefully they don't prosecute
isn't that crazy you go to melrose to go
get a vape sweater and then someone
tries to jack you so you shoot them back
there was people there was like i mean
this is another melrose like news report
that's not today we're not covering but
there was a thing where um
they were jacking kids walking the
fairfax hot oh i heard about that
yeah
but it was other girls like older girls
going over there and jacking younger
high school girls for their phones
it's right in front of urban outfitters
oh my god well there's a ton of cameras
like they're not scared of this bro
but the fairfax street mark the street
fair is so cool
right when you get in the fence i think
you're a little bit safer but when you
walk to your car and that [ __ ] is like
damn mad max dude
in broad daylight too that's the crazy
that's the part that's scary because
look at this [ __ ] that's as broad
daylight as you can get and why would
you need to the the weird thing is
what's going through his head when he
thinks he needs to equip himself with a
knife against unarmed and he wasn't even
like his friend was throwing down with
this right like he came out of nowhere
who the [ __ ] is this how do we defend
this guy though if we have to okay
defend okay we're his lawyer we're the
lawyer we're the lawyer yeah justify the
attorney he's racist
that's a good one
dude you're right yeah yeah she's racist
because we don't know when she was
yelling to him saying some crazy [ __ ]
you're right he was trying to give the
knife back to her and because it was her
knife
oh but she had it the wrong way yeah
he [ __ ] up he was like oh [ __ ] i'm
trying to return this to handle [ __ ] he
didn't grow up learning about how to
carry scissors he didn't know the sheath
was it wasn't on he didn't want to go
like this yeah the sheath of excalibur
because then he was going to cut his
hand yeah he didn't want to cut his hand
out like yeah here here here oh yeah
cause she might yeah she might have the
sheath here
she's like in her hip at me and i'll put
it back in and then she kept moving so
this it didn't go in the right place
wow that looks so stupid because you
know how samurai homies yeah they're so
stay still like you just go like i'll
put yours back well you know like
cowboys they're like oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't feel
like that's a thing samurai homies by
the way
samurai homies you don't know samurai
they don't grab their own sword they
grab each other
and then after and then after we we
defeat our enemies we go back
if you don't drill that and you don't
have the chemistry with that person it
ain't gonna work so he took off because
he was embarrassed yeah and he's like
[ __ ] and he goes oh my god i think i
stabbed her as he's walking away he's
just saving face by just bouncing after
the you know but it also looked like he
fell too like yeah he tripped a little
bit okay damn dude hopefully he got hit
by a car on the way
hopefully he got hit by a bus okay
if you guys had to stab somebody what
would it be over
some dunks bro delicious food
the i think the the pies chicken is
pretty justified okay delicious what
will i stab somebody else do you try to
rob me yeah someone trying to you would
only do self defense why the idea you're
a good law man
if someone's trying to rob me just take
it yeah it's not worth a life wait but
if you're trying to take your chickens
so it is like some materialistic [ __ ]
okay
to defend myself i would stab somebody
if we're being serious all of a sudden
how could you laugh about that
if someone tried to stab someone they
cared about i think i would stab him but
then you just continue the cycle of
stabbing that's true defend your point
jerk off
well you got you just end the cycle you
go
oh the final snap
dude what about you how would you yeah
who would you what's your situation
who'd you stab and why
i would love to stop kanye because i
feel like he would say some
crazy [ __ ] like his reaction
would be crazy like ow don't you know
i'm invincible yeah yeah yeah
just to get a reaction so you'd put his
phone in his hand hey tweet tweet how
you feel because he's so reactive oh he
wouldn't make a if he survived he would
make a dope song exactly
[Laughter]
you wouldn't stab anyone on so on under
every circumstance where you're being
robbed you will always give the idol
i think always path of least resistance
least amount of violence is the best
what if i wanted them cheeks
i don't know i don't even know if i can
get back there you know
i'm going to try it hey just kegel the
[ __ ] out of him like when he gets in
yeah you break me
rip his dick
it goes fast though i might make him
come all harder than me yeah
all right man
that's a video dude
[Music]
[Music]
you